the whole time i wasn't hungry i was
like i can't wait to get home
and now that i'm here i'm kind of miss
hungry a little bit well party
i miss the smells of edgar ramirez
hey bobby tell me more he has a spicy
smell about him you know
and when he walks by he's a soft guy too
you know i mean he's got a little hair
on his forearms
soft guy um i just smell like there's a
mist
there's a sexual mist that he exudes
from his body a pheromone
a fair is that a pheromone yeah i think
so yeah so i miss um
it's that was the most pleasurable thing
about
the trip because we talked about how
he was your hall pass oh wow right so i
didn't know he was in the movie
oh so it was a surprise no he i i think
he was cast when
i got there right or the deal closed and
then
so then i hear my friend um
jlc she goes um oh my god did he just
abbreviate jamie lee curtis no i didn't
abbreviate
i have a friend named jlc who's that i
don't know he was in the movie jesus l
christ
and she goes um oh edgar comes in
tomorrow or something and i go edgar who
she goes
edgar ramirez and i went like my uh
you have you have to understand i go
he's in our movie
yeah and glc is like you know jamie lee
curtis was like
oh she's really curious she was like um
yeah and so
i saw him in the lobby when he came in
and i went that's my girlfriend's hall
pass
but nowhere in my mind did i think like
we were gonna be friends
oh man because at that point you know
when you go i'll just tell you so when i
got there i'm like okay this is gonna be
a month and a half
of sheer boredom because
i'm not gonna no one's gonna wanna hang
out with me and also on top of it it's
like
i'm barely in the movie like the first
two weeks you called me crying yeah i
cried it was like
i'm barely in the movie i have like
six lines here six lines there
one line periodically you know what i
mean
but maybe 10 to 12 lines to the whole
thing
and um i don't know what i'm doing
anyway um so i'm thinking you know
oh they're not gonna i'm like an extra
right but i'm still
in the four seasons with everyone else
right
mm-hmm and i just what i i feel like i'm
not bragging but
it's like a castle who's who's hollywood
now who's the most hollywood i'm not
hollywood at all i'm i'm telling you
that i'm not i mean hollywood
would have been like oh i can't wait to
go there to befriend all these people
and live amongst the hollywood elite my
thing is like i got to combat these
people and i gotta survive
so that's not what hollywood is right
wait that's the hotel yeah that's insane
it's a castle that's literally
that's literally where i stayed for a
month that's a hotel
so when you walk in you're like bro dude
what
see the first floor right there yeah is
that you is that your place yeah
that's me right there the lights out
lights up and then glc
no she's right here she'll see above you
or
next to you this right here has a
balcony and a whole thing
oh man yeah yeah that's amazing so i'm
in this castle right so you
imagine like i'm checking in right yeah
and i'm in this
cat oh no i'll just tell you what
happened so this is how i knew
i was in the beginning i was i thought i
was [ __ ] because
so i land right with janina
yeah she's talented so good now janina
and cheyenne jackson
i mean this dude has it all
cheyenne jackson has it all bro the
looks
dances he can skip dance and skip dance
tap dancing
tap dance skip skip dancing
skip dance i don't know see dancing show
me what a skip dance was
like yeah
[Laughter]
and then um so we land and
there's a guy in a full-blown suit and
he
goes to janine right when we get off the
plane and he goes up to genie and goes
um
come with me young lady and then
cheyenne and i are just going with
everyone else
because she has like a concierge limo
kind of situation
so that's what they do is when you she's
vip she's vip
for sure for sure but then she goes hey
well
cheyenne and bob just come with me
what's the big deal
right and the guy was like i don't know
if that's a part of the you know what i
mean and she's like
they're they're in the movie just so we
went in through
the like we went into like a whole
beautiful like
lounge area first time vip yeah i've
never been vip
oh right this whole lounge area and it's
like
i'm like oh this is how they treat you
and also you you think
this is gonna be my treatment to the
whole thing like i'm gonna
be pulled along and tagged along so then
we go to the
hotel and you know that hotel and you go
and you're like oh my god this is
gorgeous and then something magical
happened
why are you making that face am i being
meanwhile i just have a different
account
of events from oh from
the magic didn't happen fast the first
two weeks was you calling no no no no
that's not true
ten times that's that's true i am so
close
i'm lonely that's not true that's not
true that's true i'll tell you i'll tell
you
the first five days was great
and then the two weeks of me calling
going i'm gonna kill myself
so that's i'm describing the first five
days
no because remember i got the letter
that's what i'm describing yeah yeah
so i get the letter from jlc i gave you
a letter she wrote me a letter it's
upstairs oh my god you want me a letter
you know what i mean hey let's you know
she goes welcome to the
show you know what i mean my name is
jamie lee curtis
you know bobby um you know maybe we'll
develop a relationship i don't know what
that's so sweet it's very sweet
and it has you know her name on the like
printed on
also knowing what kind of guy you are
and like how like
nervous you get in these types of things
the fact that someone would like reach
out and be like hey
let's go get lunch let me buy by the way
i i'm not
she's better a better person than i've
ever met
anyone else in the industry no in life
really in [ __ ] life bro
she's just there's not a bad bone in her
body man
she's just like she does back rubs like
you know how you're like hanging out at
a
lunch or something and she'll just do
just rub your back and then
a [ __ ] up person like me will count
how long
she's rubbing you because i'm like in
20 more seconds i'm out you know me if
she keeps rubbing i'm gonna have to do
something like why what would you do or
like i'm gonna go have a cigarette or
whatever
or something or something yeah but she's
you know she's a rubber motherly
in a way motherly way so she wrote a
letter and then
that night she texted me i don't know
how she's gonna she goes
lunge tomorrow at noon i love this
already
why she's like so like um like a mother
hen yeah and also it's like imagine
me being scared me thinking i'm not
gonna be able to meet anybody
so i meet her at noon downstairs at the
restaurant and janine is there
cheyenne's there
and penn gilletzer he's in
oh wow you know penn jillette oh my
favorite magician yeah yeah
so penn jillette's there and um we just
had this dinner
and then kevin hart walks by with his
entourage like
50 people yeah but they're like
beautiful people
okay and his his two
bodyguards are a little suspect i love
those
guys [ __ ] those guys remember what
happened yeah they're a little suspect
they're bullies they're not they were
still i i'll have to say they're bullies
so so this is this is during the two
weeks that bobby was very lonely and he
was eating in uh
i don't know if four seasons would call
it a cafeteria because it's a lot
higher class than that but they had like
a restaurant in the in the
yeah yeah hotel that you would eat at
free everyone would eat there
and so um this is when he was really
lonely and um
he was really needing some type of like
reassurance
and so he sees kevin hart's bodyguards
and he's already built some type of
rapport with them
and so he he was he facetimes me he's
like hey babe i'm eating over here
and he and he goes over to kevin hart's
bodyguards he was like hey guys i want
you to meet my girlfriend
but as he turns the phone i turn my
phone to my cat's face
and so they're only looking at a cat
yeah and they were like
damn dude you went to bestiality and let
me just say this yeah that was a running
joke for a month
i'm saying it to everybody yo yo yo that
guy's [ __ ] he loves cats
he was like he doesn't have a girlfriend
dude he has a cat yeah yeah wait so
that's i think that's the words were
they the bullies or i think you were
like
you were the you ignited it but it was
such a perfect
shot of gooner like he was just kind of
like this yeah
so anyway um no i love those guys and
and so that
so then that lunch happened and then um
i went i went to shoot and um
it was like um i don't well let's tell
people what i'm in
all right so there's a movie called
borderlands and it's about
it's based on the video game and eli
roth
is directing it and it's got a lot of
big people jamie lee curtis
edgar ramirez kate blanchett kevin hart
jack jack black plays claptrap
the robot and then there's uh janina's
in it and she's
she saved my life by the way that girl i
love that girl and then um
my little friend from england charles
yeah
there it is yeah i'm not in there
florian's in this
oh wow guys do you know florian yeah he
was in a creep too he's jacked he's huge
yeah yeah i like florian so that's it so
that's what was that's in the movie
and that's who was in the hotel and um
but then so i so i went to shoot right
so you go to this desert
and it's like thousands of people
oh like extras like and i play a soldier
right
much like see right below where edgar
ramirez's photo
yeah that's basically what we're wearing
okay this red like
stormtrooper suit metal
the whole thing it's in it's hot as [ __ ]
and there's hundreds of us in the desert
and i'm wearing the so they're like put
the helmet on
they put my head in a ponytail it was a
beautiful ponytail
yeah thank you the helmet wouldn't fit
mm-hmm of course yeah it's yeah my
head's too big for my body
and so they're like about to shoot so
the [ __ ]
wardrobe they [ __ ] start yanking out
all the padding
oh like last minute last minute just
ripping all the right
they finally get on my head what they
don't realize is
without the padding if they're just
metal
spikes right scraping like this two
four metal spots right here in my eye
pushing my eye in
it's a heavy [ __ ] metal thing and all
as soon as
it's on my head i start getting a
headache right and i'm going
out right and i'm sweating too i'm
sweating this
right and the tank takes for 20 minutes
it's like the people are just running
with [ __ ] machine guns and
there's you know me you know i mean
machi uh spacecrafts yeah you know i
mean
all kinds of [ __ ] going on meanwhile i'm
with a gun
in the desert with with a hundred and
then and then the
and then the [ __ ] um sound guy goes
you know you're gonna be wearing that
helmet the whole time
oh my god he thought you were an extra
yeah and i go what do you mean
because even when you say you're lying
you're going to wear the helmet
i guess so no one's going to know i'm in
the movie
[Laughter]
and he goes nope so imagine for the
first six hours i'm
in the desert with that information in
my head my head in pain
yeah right with the thing going
oh this is hell this is hell on earth
but also i i want to so do i want
everyone to like me so desperately
i don't complain right i don't go hey
you know
i think i'm gonna go blind bleeding yeah
yeah yeah yeah
so then um then at six hours later
they have a scene where me and janina i
hand her a gun and i go
there's a creature we should shoot it
you know i mean and i said it
i said it with the helmet on in
rehearsal yeah and then eli comes into
me goes hey man
um why are you wearing the helmet oh you
wore the helmet yeah because the guy
that sound guy
[ __ ] you [ __ ] me over for six hours my
question was wouldn't why wouldn't you
question
that because they did your hair so
beautifully if you had to wear the
helmet the whole time why do they put so
much effort into your hair
oh yeah i i but that doesn't come to my
head because it's like
why do they why are they like adjusting
like one little tiny [ __ ] nail on
your
shoe yeah you mean they're so like
precise about everything so
i don't know right but then you know eli
goes you're not wearing the helmet
you're [ __ ]
come on man the sound guy
guy sergey yeah he said you know what i
mean
at this point what were your eyes like i
had like definitely like spots on my
face
on my head but i didn't wear the helmet
again through the whole movie
poor babe and then i and then there you
go and then you're there for like 16
hours
just standing there in the desert and
then
the next day i think okay i'm going to
stand in the desert still more
that's fine but then all of a sudden
they go
oh we switched things around you we're
doing your scene
i don't know oh you don't know i don't
know what
oh man i don't know the scene i thought
it was next week
so they're switching it around let's go
let's go to the the the church because
and with kevin kevin's waiting for you
to rehearse so i'm just like
oh my god and you go there and it's like
hundreds of people
cameras everyone's there stressing eliza
and
i rehearsed it and i [ __ ] nailed it
good job babe i nailed the first take
then i shot one scene
like one tank and eli just basically
goes just just do another one
we got it it's excellent how papa has
grown
and then he texted me that night really
really cool
is that my goodness this is gross where
the end of the no this is great i like i
like this stuff as a someone that you
know
i don't think i think you're gonna make
fun of me no i'm not so he literally
texted me
and he emailed me and he goes i'm so
glad i hired you
you killed it and ever then after that
i could talk to people i see why are you
smiling like that
no you're acting gross you're like
you're thinking that i'm saying
something
oh my i'm not doing anything i'm just
telling you the way it is baby so wait
after that you got sad
then after that they're like all right
you have two and a half weeks off
she hey guys we're gonna take a really
quick break to share some of our like
favorite sponsors
ziprecruiter.com